the Bills have gotten a new defensive
back Josh Norman after being cut by
Washington when his former coach Ron
Rivera shows up to take over in
Washington
Norman reunites with his former
defensive coordinator Shawn McDermott in
Buffalo now Norman never really lived up
to that 15 million dollar a year
contract he was good not great I
remember his first game in Washington
Chris people were like why isn't he
covered in Antonio Brown why is Bashar
Breeland covering Antonio Brown well
Josh Norman doesn't travel well why the
hell are they paying in 15 million a
year and I think his career there was
always clouded by that reality less
money lower expectations and and maybe a
guy who can help make a difference in
Buffalo this is what you do with free
agents you have your core team that you
built via the draft and then you use
free agency to selectively add certain
areas where you have a deficiency yeah
right and they got a deficiency there
you know they've got some corners and
secondary people who are gonna hit free
agency you know a Levi Wallace who's
restricted but Josh Norman you know at
the very least is a proven commodity and
understands how to play in that Shawn
McDermott scheme which is not a manned
Amman travel with the best type of wide
receiver type scheme that's not what
they do and of course when they do do
that which is not a whole lot they're
not gonna ask Josh Norman to go against
the number one anymore because they have
toured a via suede so that makes a lot
of sense I think it was a good signing
for them not only to just you know
become a better defense and have a
better starting corner out there but
gives them more depth and of course some
familiarity there as well and then you
know you mentioned it like yeah he's not
a travel island Amanda Mann type corner
and here we are in the era of like hey
the next guy got gets a new contract or
gets the most money in his position
every time right if you're in the top
five or top ten conversation to your
position I mean Josh Norman was so
overpaid with the Washington Redskins
and that was such a horrible contract by
them we're still really have one corner
in football that makes 15 million
dollars a year and that's Xavier Howard
Josh Norman signed that contract would
you say three or four years ago I can't
remember now but that's to me 2016 that
was right
yeah that shows you how insane that
contract was I mean that's just it was
stupid on the Redskins I don't know what
else to say there and yeah I mean we're
still looking at top corners right now
in football asking to be paid maybe 15
million dollars per year so I like the
signing that old contract was ridiculous
and just to show you how dysfunctional
the team was under Bruce Allen I mean
good lord they should have cut him last
year yeah right right at the at the
latest they should have cut him last
year and now he's gone making a lot less
but maybe making an impact with the
Buffalo Bill
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports